we've all been there but luckily this
situation may not be around for much
longer that's why we've helped create a
next generation credential we call them
pass keys at apple's worldwide developer
conference in june the company talked
about how it's working with microsoft
google and about 250 other companies to
eliminate the need for passwords that's
across many internet services when this
idea comes to fruition all you'll need
is a fingerprint or a face scan and
that's it you're in no more passwords if
you're wondering how that'll work i'll
key you in get it key you in
a lot of you had questions about the
passwordless future article i wrote back
in june so stick around until the end
because i asked the companies and i have
a couple answers for you but first let's
talk about the problem passwords suck
many people not only hate passwords but
they can't be bothered to use secure
ones if you're responsible and actually
set up a secure complex password guess
what you still have to remember them or
find some other way to save them
credentials get leaked in data breaches
all the time and they tend to have other
security issues too but before i get all
excited let's take a look at what this
might look like in practice apple says
password list logins will look something
like this when you go to sign in to an
account you just tap the username field
which prompts a face id scan and you're
in notice the password box literally
goes away that's because pass keys are
hardware based but they're also still
accessible across operating systems but
what's happening behind the scenes the
cross-platform functionality is enabled
by a security standard that's set by the
fast identity online alliance aka fido
the standard calls for a pair of two
related digital keys one of the keys is
public and sits on the service
provider's servers the other is private
and can't be removed from your device
together they make up apple's passkey
system to log into an account the
operating system would connect the two
keys for apple products face id and
touch id will take care of that google
and microsoft are working on similar
offerings which might use biometrics or
a pin and if you need your apple created
pass keys to sign in on a non-apple
device by google or microsoft you'd be
presented with a qr code to scan with
your iphone which would authenticate the
login experts told me that pass keys are
resistant to phishing attacks that's
because there's no password involved and
that's by design they also can't be
leaked because nothing private is held
on a web server it's pretty monumental
for apple google and microsoft to be
working together on this but the
companies still haven't figured
everything out just yet some of your
questions spotlight this so let's dig
into a few of them what happens if your
primary device doesn't have touch id or
face id or if they don't work well for
you you can still use pass keys but your
device passcode or system password would
authenticate you instead of a face scan
or fingerprint reading you'd still be
using some type of password to log into
your accounts at least until you
upgraded to a newer device capable of
running ios 16 ipad os 16 or mac os
ventura some of you told me that you
have issues using fingerprint scanners
as you get older and fido's president
confirmed that this is a potential
problem all right next question what
happens to past keys when you die your
pass keys don't have to die along with
you but you do have to share access to
your accounts while you're still here on
apple devices you can share your pass
keys through airdrop which means you
have to be within bluetooth range of the
other person you just go to where your
password settings are and find the login
you'd like to share with someone google
says it's working on a way for apps to
generate unique pass keys for users on
shared accounts the president of fido
told me if you share a bank account for
instance you'd have a unique set of pass
keys for you and a unique pair for the
other person it's like having two really
secured unique passwords for just one
account but if you don't plan ahead it's
much harder for people to access your
account data companies told me you can
opt out of using pass keys if you want
to which means you can continue to just
use passwords or you can set up a
password as a backup in case your
phone's biometric system isn't working a
passwordless future won't arrive
overnight but personally i can't wait
for a time where i don't have to worry
about leaked passwords or weak passwords
really any passwords
you